estos 17.000 pesos también 17
estos Como cuánto mira como 20 amiga
creo como 20 en el armario de Grecia hay
decenas de zapatos y prendas de lujo la
joven de 28 años y su amiga Leslie
invierte en todo su dinero y su tiempo
en su apariencia cierto
160 Esta última lipo las bubis como como
80 y los hombres están acostumbrados a
andar con mujeres rigurosas voluptuosas
y así tú no tienes nalgas o estás toda
desagradada tú sabes cómo son
lo tiene Ay Así son aquí es la cultura
en Culiacán muchas mujeres como Grecia
recurren a la cirugía estética para
moldear sus cuerpos la mayoría aspira a
parecerse a la figura de la buchona una
mujer con curvas generosas vinculada a
la narcocultura un personaje que se creó
aquí en la capital del Cartel De Sinaloa
[Música]
muchas de esas mujeres pues tienen
relaciones afectivas con con narcos con
personas que se dedican al narcotráfico
y que ellos son los que patrocinan o les
pagan esas esas cirugías es también un
modo aspiracional de ser como de estar
como de vivir en ese ambiente o de no
vivirlo simplemente estar a la moda y
decir Bueno yo no soy narcotraficante ni
tengo un novio ni pareja ni esposo que
me pague esta cirugías yo las las puedo
pagar y quiero estar quiero ser como
ellas en las calles de la ciudad las
clínicas de cirugía estética están bien
establecidas en las redes sociales
páginas especializadas prometen
resultados espectaculares a precios
atractivos pero la mayoría de los
cirujanos que operan detrás de esas
páginas no están calificados en cirugía
estética mutilan a pacientes que después
llegan a la mesa de operaciones de la
doctora Martínez Terrazas tiene
desgarrado el músculo el pectoral y hay
que reconstruirlo porque en ciertas
actividades le genera dolor el implante
se va hacia arriba le genera molestias
es frecuente este que tengamos que
reconstruir pacientes lesionadas por
cirugías mal hechas por mala praxis es
un fenómeno difícil de controlar en el
y había un cirujano plástico por cada 20
pseudo cirujanos la paciente de hoy es
Cristina hace un año y medio esta mujer
de 48 años se puso unas prótesis
mamarias la operación fue realizada por
un médico que no estaba diplomado en
cirugía estética Poco después del
procedimiento sintió un dolor anormal
los días Se me inflamó una bubis que
parecía que me iba a reventar dice
malísima y me agarró mucho dolor y me
tuve que ir me dijo que fuera más otra
vez a Mazatlán pues me fui a operar otra
vez y me volvió a cobrar llegó un
momento en que le había dicho doctor ya
no aguanto pues ya lo único que lo único
que hay me dijo para esto Pues toma o
ponte unos parches de morfina algo así
la coepris la comisión contra riesgos
sanitarios rastrea esas clínicas
clandestinas desde enero de 2022 de los
168 establecimientos inspeccionados en
Sinaloa 28 fueron clausurados como el
quirófano que se ve en se ve una cama
muy simple Se ve que existe una ventana
misma es que no pueden existir porque
favorece la contaminación del área pero
cerrar oficialmente esos
establecimientos no es sencillo hay un
nombre de un médico que conocen lo
escuchan saben y así pero se dan cuenta
que sigue ejerciendo que sigue
ejerciendo es correcto ante la ausencia
de Procedimientos Penales adecuados esos
pseudocirujanos causan estragos desde
hace mucho tiempo hace 18 años una amiga
invitó a Leticia a su casa para hacerse
una supuesta inyección de ácido
hialurónico en las nalgas ahora hace
parte de las víctimas de los
procedimientos estéticos los cinco años
se me empezó a oscurecer la piel
y
después de oscurecer la piel se me
empezó a adelgazar mucho entonces una
vez me golpeé
caí para atrás sentada y sangre tanto
que que no podía parar de de sangrar
esto es una tragedia para tu vida que ya
no vuelve a ser igual que tu vida ya no
ya no vuelve a ser igual si es que
logras
salvar tu vida porque a veces no logran
salvar su vida desde enero de 2022 en
Sinaloa han fallecido tres personas por
cirugías estéticas mal hechas en México
el parlamento está evaluando un proyecto
de ley para enjuiciar penalmente a
aquellos médicos que no estén
calificados y evitar que sigan
ejerciendo el proceso puede tardar hasta
un año